[Música]
el regreso de los gobiernos selectos de
izquierda en América Latina y en
particular la llegada de Gustavo Petro
al poder en Colombia le han devuelto a
Nicolás Maduro cierto protagonismo en la
escena internacional también importancia
política en nuestra región de América
Latina esto se podría además reforzar
con el posible regreso al poder de Luis
Ignacio lulada Silva en Brasil saludamos
entonces Alejandro Cardozo suscate y
geles doctor en historia politólogo y
profesor de política y relaciones
internacionales de la universidad Sergio
arboleda en Colombia Alejandro buena
mañana Gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo América de Francia 24 hablamos
entonces de este regreso por decirlo de
alguna manera del presidente Nicolás
Maduro a la escena internacional y por
qué se ha visto impulsado
Hola Buenos días Este Bueno
la resiliencia autoritaria del madurado
pues ha demostrado ser eficiente aguantó
la peor parte del momento diplomático de
aislamiento y ahora como tú lo dices en
tu introducción Pues esta nueva
reversión del péndulo vamos a decir así
del pie del péndulo regional hacia
gobiernos progresistas pues le dan
oxígeno a maduro sobre todo y por encima
de todos El Triunfo de de Gustavo Petro
en Colombia apertura de relaciones
comerciales Nuevo Horizonte energético
que se suma también pues a las
necesidades del mercado energético
global que están atravesando y van a
atravesar un peor momento cuando el
invierno son digamos
escenarios que van a favorecer a la
política exterior en esta reinserción en
la región de Nicolás maduro
porque Alejandro fracasó esta presión
que mantuvo la comunidad internacional
sobre todo los países occidentales
durante buen tiempo más de más de un año
no contra Nicolás Maduro digamos
apoyando al líder opositor Juan guaidó
Juan guaidó ya digamos sale un poco por
no digamos completo no en la escena
internacional para ahora reconocer
alguna manera el el el la presidencia de
Nicolás maduro no obviamente se vio
afianzada por la guerra en Ucrania
cuando Estados Unidos pues se acercó al
gobierno venezolano con respecto al
petróleo debido a que no podía digamos
ya tenerlo tenerlo de Rusia
bueno el Yo pienso que en el manual de
cómo presionar Gobierno autoritarios ya
deben sacar por favor el capítulo de
aislamiento internacional y bloqueo
porque definitivamente no funciona no
funciona este vimos que al contrario se
fortaleció y digamos que tuvo medidas
tuvo por lo menos causas razones motivos
legítimos para intensificar su presión
polisiva supresión autoritaria en la
sociedad venezolana a partir del bloqueo
se creó inclusive una ley antibloqueo
por otro lado
todas las iniciativas prodemocráticas en
torno al presidente encargado a Juan
guaidó se vieron también muy afectadas
por escándalos de corrupción de su
propio entorno de su propio entorno Así
mismo con pues informes que se
publicaron en la prensa estadounidense
en el Washington post sobre
que la coalición que apoyaba guaidó
también estuvo involucrada en aquella
operación de desembarco en las costas de
la guaira en Caracas la llamada
operación galeón entonces varios
elementos y sobre todo la corrupción en
su entorno
recordemos la junta directiva de
monómeros en Colombia que que el
presidente anterior reconoció como la
verdadera gerencia de esa empresa
venezolano colombiana También estuvo
involucrada en ciertas irregularidades
esto merma la legitimidad de guaidó y el
eje de resistencia a favor de él pues
empieza a debilitar al mismo tiempo el
Nicolás Maduro empieza a fortalecerse
por la reapertura regional y la
aceptación la nueva tolerancia hacia su
gobierno la escena regional hablemos de
esa esa apertura regional digamos en
América Latina Alejandro por supuesto
con la llegada de Gustavo Petro al poder
en Colombia no también los diálogos con
la guerrilla del ejército de liberación
nacional en ponerle el Ln que se llevan
a cabo en Caracas
Obviamente con la ayuda del gobierno
venezolano como eso también favoreció a
una a una protagonismo más activo de
Nicolás maduro
es exactamente bueno comienzo por lo
último el protagonismo activo que
Nicolás Maduro adquiere a través de ser
un puente de diálogo entre lln y el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro es muy
importante revitaliza el rol diplomático
de Venezuela después de haber estado
dormido por dos tres años lo revitaliza
de paso repitiendo digamos un guión que
fuese que fue exitoso que fue el mismo
guión que hizo Hugo Chávez como puente
para las negociaciones del presidente
Entonces el presidente Santos con La
FARC Recuerden que Chávez fue clave para
poder
establecer una primera fase de diálogo
entre La FARC y el entonces gobierno de
Colombia en Cuba Chávez le da la llave a
al presidente Santos de La Habana para
que puedan entonces llevar a una primera
fase de negociación que termina
posteriormente en oslo y evidentemente
es un éxito de la administración este
guión se quiere repetir este con lln una
guerrilla residual mucho menos mucho
menos en su momento en su mejor momento
mucho menos grande que La FARC pero es
como el último capítulo que queda por
abordar para la paz y la conciliación
colombiana Entonces el presidente Santos
lo otorga esta confianza el presidente
de Petro perdón el presidente Petro
otorga esta confianza de diálogo de
Puente diplomático a pesar de las
fuertes reacciones que hay en contra de
ellos al presidente maduro a Nicolás
maduro y bueno y vuelve entonces a la
escena diplomática repitiendo como te
digo el mismo guión
bueno se nos queda por fuera digamos el
acercamiento que puede tener también el
gobierno venezolano con la posible
llegada nuevamente de Lula da Silva en
Brasil al poder eso ya pues lo
conversaremos en otra oportunidad
Alejandro Muchísimas gracias por su
tiempo por estar con nosotros en directo
América